hey guys dr. berg I had another question about
what is the best nuts on a ketogenic diet this
might surprise you check this out what I did is
I took the total carbs minus the fiber to get
the net carb okay then I added the fat grams
next to it because ideally if you're doing a
ketogenic diet you want more fat right and we
want low net carbs so the winner look at this
peak on 14 total grams carbs minus 10 for net
gram carbs 71 fat so pecans are the best nut
to consume because it has the lowest net carb
believe it or not maybe you thought it would be
macadamia nuts but that's the 7 grams but the
advantage of the macadamia nut is it has high
amounts of fat which probably offsets some of the
small amount of insulin response so anything up
here is really good so Brazil nuts 6 grams 88
grams of fat walnuts give you 6 grams of net
carbs 52 grams of fat and almonds we got started
getting up to 9 grams which doesn't have as much
fat 45 and then we have pine nuts pine nuts
have 13 grams in 92 grams of fat so pine nuts
are really good on a ketogenic diet because it's
high in fat it's close to the macadamia nuts okay
then we get almond butter almond butter has a 21
now I just want to let you know this is based on
cups okay one cup you're not going to consume
a cup of any of these but I just wanted to give
you a relative value of if you're having a
small amount of course this is going to be
a lot less okay but I just want to compare of
equal magnitude of one nut versus another nut
check this out almond butter 21 grams 139 grams
of fat but look at peanut butter over here peanut
butter has 35 grams compared to 21 grams for
almond butter so I would highly recommend you
do almond butter and not peanut butter because it
has more carbs they both have very similar amounts
of fat actually the almond has more fat then
we have the pistachio which is 21 grams of net
carb but again you're going to do small amount
56 grams of fat and then we have cashews which
is the worst nut because it has 35 grams of net
carb 62 grams of fat which is a lot lower than
these other ones so you want to avoid cashews so
if you're going to have a nut I would stick with
pecans where any of these up here would be good
small amounts so hopefully we solve the mystery
of what is the best nut to consume on a ketogenic
diet hi guys hey listen I created a pretty amazing
evaluation quiz down below that actually analyzes
your symptoms to find the cause the root cause of
all of your symptoms the most likely cause so
take the quiz now and we'll send you report